this morning here in Las Vegas Nevada
where I am for the mass torts made
perfect conference as I often M up every
year I stopped by the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum which you can
find at david pakman.com slash reddit a
lot of really really good discussions
going on there I'll go through a couple
of them with you in the wake of Donald
Trump's tax plan and me talking about
debt and deficit there's a really good
post on reddit about the difference
between deficit and debt which is
something that is really confusing to
many many people and there's a really
good analogy made to speed versus
distance and a nice conversation is
starting around that so very very good
post by stapl hill on our reddit
discussion forum also from the reddit
discussion forum an interesting
conversation has started about how
President Obama is being paid $400,000
for a wall street speech and this has
actually generated a lot of really
interesting discussion of course Hillary
Clinton heavily criticized for having
given paid Wall Street speeches at the
same time others argued that hey she got
paid to give her opinion and there's no
evidence that her policies were dictated
by the fact that Wall Street paid her
others disagree and now there is a
conversation about is Obama in some way
selling out by getting paid by Wall
Street or is this what presidents do
they give a former president they give
speeches and get paid differing opinions
on the reddit discussion forum and I
encourage you to participate in that
also from the read discussion forum a
thread inquires
about whether the david pakman show is
just collateral damage with regard to
the YouTube advertiser boycott in the
sense that it doesn't really have
anything to do with the content of the
David Pakman show
in terms of why we're suffering from the
YouTube advertiser boycott but rather
that were just collateral damage because
of broader changes that YouTube has been
making to their policy interesting
conversation over 20 comments posted
there so far and I encourage you to
participate there
really good discussion with nearly 50
comments at this point about how do we
actually get money out of politics we
often talk about the importance of
getting out money out of politics we
talk about the corrosive impact of money
in politics
but how would we actually get money out
of politics really really good
conversation there and then lastly a
thread commenting on the timing of the
YouTube live streams which I've been
doing as good a job as I can of
scheduling them on YouTube when I know
when I'm going to do one but it's
usually you know at the most a few hours
ahead of time and conversation about
that people still generally liking the
live streams and they continue to do
well so I will do what I can to schedule
them as far in advance as possible but
my message to you is participate join
the reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it you can join in
on other discussions start your own a
lot of good stuff going on there